can europe be weaned off russian gas
leaders are worried that moscow will
turn off the taps if tensions with
ukraine worsen but will the alternatives
be enough to fuel europe's energy needs
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
imran khan
russia's the biggest source of natural
gas for europe it's crucial for heating
up homes especially during the winter
moscow's disrupted gas flows in the past
for political purposes for example when
russia annexed crimea in 2014. so as
tensions on ukraine worsen european
leaders are worried about history being
repeated
the united states is scrambling to help
its european allies secure alternatives
it's negotiating with oil and gas
supplies in north africa the middle east
and asia the emir of qatar the world's
largest producer of liquefied natural
gas or lng is due to meet at the u.s
president on monday washington concedes
diverting global glass supplies will be
a huge task
no question there are logistical
challenges of especially moving uh
natural gas uh we we know that uh that's
part of our discussion with a lot of
these companies and countries um but
again these conversations are ongoing
and we don't intend to fail on them
europe gets more than 40 of its natural
gas from russia but a third of that
passes through ukraine
moscow has already reduced the amount
flowing into europe causing shortages
and pushing prices to record levels
now russia's threatening to cut supplies
further if sanctions are imposed and
they're not just on gas but also on oil
and metals some countries depend on
russia more than others germany gets
more than half of its gas supplies from
russia and that dependency would
increase if the german government gives
its final approval to the nordstrom 2
pipeline
let's bring in our guests in moscow
pavel phil genhauer a defensive military
analyst in bern cornelia mayer ceo of
mayor resource and a specialist in oil
and gas and in berlin ulrich brookner a
professor of political science at
stanford university in berlin welcome to
the program let's begin in bern with uh
colina meyer collina this is not as easy
as
russia switching off uh the gas pipeline
and america coming to rescue with lots
of new natural gases it's a lot more
complicated than that
oh it's much much more complicated
because you know these um gas pipelines
the pipeline gas from russia that dates
50 60 years back and these are old
relationships and and europe only gets
that much um lng gas which can which
comes partially from the us
um
so it it's not quite it's not quite that
easy and for russia it's also different
than it was last time around which is
2014
when the crimean ukraine crisis happened
because at that time russia was totally
dependent for its energy revenues on
europe
now
about 30 plus percent of its oil goes to
china 40 plus percent to oceania and
and in in terms of gas also the chinese
um uh
off-take is increasing so whilst it's
still 72 percent
um it's it's dwindling so we are in a
very very different economic and
geopolitical environment uh pavel
falgenhauer that does that mean that
russia has in some respects some regards
the upper hand here it can actually
threaten to cut supplies but not
completely because it doesn't need the
money but that does have an impact on
europe
well the russian official position is
that russia will not threaten or cut
supplies
but if there's going to be a further
escalation maybe even some fighting on
the border that would more or less
effectively actually technically cut the
gas and supply at least through ukraine
and so that's a situation where russian
gas supplies the europe could be
drastically cut and maybe could be cut
all together and that would be bad for
everyone
because russia yes it has right now
being supplying some natural gas to
ukraine to
to china
we're building up the capability to
export some liquefied gas in the north
but still the main russians
the rain russian client is
europe and of course russia itself
russia supplies a lot of gas to its own
people and some industries but europe is
of course very important you can't
really divert right now technically the
gas that goes to europe again diverted
to china that just simply or some other
kind of market that that won't work so
this is going to be if there's going to
be a cut i believe but
all will try to make it very short
because it's going to be disastrous for
all sides
ulrich brookner in um berlin this is not
just a case of kind of geopolitics being
played out but it's also geo business as
well these pipelines aren't just run by
countries they're run by corporations
a lot of those corporations are going to
lose billions of dollars if this goes on
for any length of time do they have a
say in what russia might be able to do
well i wouldn't think too much of the
influence of corporations but it is very
clear that it's not only about
geopolitics it's also about business the
united states became in december the
largest produced producer of liquefied
gas
and they are fracking industry all over
the country urgently needs to explore
new markets so it was very hard for
everyone in the united states to
understand
why an ally like germany
signs a deal with russia
to enhance the dependency when the
united states provides security and
germany buys even more gas
from russia at times when we declare
that because of climate change we will
reduce the energy hunger that stems from
fossil fuels
that's a very interesting point um miss
meyer let's uh take that up with you
there is a like we're talking about
not just business but we're talking
about politics as well however we have
an interesting point there the americans
provide security to germany yet
germany's buying gas from russia
is why is that happening
well you know that there is a very
historic relationship between russia and
um and germany and and and and the
german the russo german business goes
well beyond gas
um but um but but your uh germany needs
gas to heat its houses and when you look
at what happened over the last few
months in terms of the escalating gas
prices and the inflation coming from it
it was was quite um something you know
uh 400 percent more 500 percent more so
that was quite
quite a bit so in that sense um if you
are
this is important and yes we all want to
do we all want to be less dependent on
fossil fuels but that energy transition
is not going to happen overnight and let
us not forget that gas is the cleanest
fossil fuel so it's a good transitional
fuel so in that sense it's important
that billions of dollars have been
invested into the north stream two
pipeline
uh pavel this is not just about then um
the the west worrying about its energy
supplies russia relies on this foreign
currency that the money it makes um from
uh oil and gas pipelines like so russia
this is going to harm russia as well
of course
any kind of uh
breakup of uh relationship with europe
or harm russia immensely
europe is russia's biggest i mean
european union is russia's biggest
trading partner although in terms of
nations uh china right now is a number
one but
as a block europe europe is more
important
and there's a lot of
really business relationship especially
between mosque russia and germany
there's a lot of connections on
different levels i mean
russian president
vladimir putin is very fluent in german
and they even addressed the bundestag
once speaking in german so the russia
was always looking to for a special
relationship with germany and germany
tried very much wants to make germany a
kind of hub for russian gas supplies to
all of western europe uh possibly
bypassing ukraine and that
would be a kind of break up of that
a violent breakup of those relationship
would be very costly in terms of
political and in terms of money too
oh look this isn't the first time we've
seen energy being used as a diplomatic
political weapon this happened in the
70s when opec decided it wasn't going to
supply uh the west with oil over a
variety of different things including
actually how much money they were
getting for for their oil so have there
been lessons learned from previous uh
situations like this or is it once again
it's going in blindly
well this is actually something that
history seems to repeat itself because
the situation in the 1970s when opec
entered the scene as a cartel
that drastically increased the not only
the energy cost but the political costs
of energy for energy hungry
industrialized countries like germany we
had a social democratic government and
the social democratic government used
the trade relations with russia as a
trust building instrument to widen the
scope of dialogue with soviet union
counterparts
to
pave the way for what then happened as
the end of the cold war
and the reunification of germany and the
reunification of the divided continent
now again we have a social democratic
government and a lot of the older
personnel is flirting with the idea that
we could do something similar try to
understand russian's vested interests
and try to build a bridge and be less
confrontational this is also strongly
supported by governors in the eastern
part of germany who also believe that
russia has a point in its line of
argumentation but germany is isolated in
that perspective and everyone else
believes that it would be far better if
the west speaks with one voice and sends
a strict signal to russia that it should
never ever cross red lines and again
violate international law so in this
mishmash energy is not just a question
of will our homes be warm but also
will germany pay a price by dropping
north stream too
uh cornelia meyer i see you kind of
disagreeing there with what our guest in
berlin had to say why why why are you
disagreeing
well i'm agreeing and i'm disagreeing i
think yes germany and the german
government um are are variant especially
in the eastern part of of of germany
they're very close to um they did they
do want to see that that energy
relationship with russia going on where
i disagree slightly is that the previous
government
with with mrs merkel it was very clear
that that
nordstrom 2 was non-negotiable and it
would go ahead you know thinking of the
billions of dollars that have been
invested you can understand why that is
the case whereas now yes olaf schultz he
is a social democrat and he wants to see
nordstrom 2 come on stream but he is in
bed or in coalition with the greens who
are very look very differently at a
fossil fuels of which gas is one and b
especially the foreign minister analina
berbak is very skeptical of russia and
human rights policy and so on and is
very vocal about it
so
yes we'll i think olaf charles still
wants to see um north streams two going
ahead
it's not quite as clear-cut as as i
think it was before the new government
uh pavel falgenhauer the emir of qatar
one of the biggest suppliers of lng
liquid nitrogen i can never say that
actually lng let's just call it gas um
has been um we'll be meeting with biden
very shortly is that of concern to the
russians
well this is an opportunity of course
for the american
gas industry to increase its share of
the european market actually they have
new export
facilities coming online soon and they
can increase their exports of
gas and natural gas and chalet gas
and
european market is a reliable market so
yes for them that's an opportunity and
also there's a political agenda there
to put the
europeans into line and kind of lead
them in a quest to against russia
and that's kind of what that how it
worked during the code work often and
now apparently it's the old uh
card table the old cards uh but with the
new meaning i mean once actually in
during the 67 war in the middle east
america was which was then an oil
exporter helped
europe out when there was an arab
uh
boycott of europe and oil exports that
time it didn't work of course in 73 it
was already very different and then it
did work and very well um but for opec
but
america now is taking on that position
and that's for them very advantageous
uh what do you think brooke now america
is taking on
effectively energy diplomacy energy
policies uh that are going to help it
with europe i mean is it that simple i
kind of think it isn't well i was really
surprised a few years ago when the
congress sanctioned
companies that are located in ally
countries in nato countries
because this was unheard of that a
country flexes muscles with such an
obvious economic interest
although we
depend on each other and we are in the
same vote when it comes to the security
alliance but coming back to the previous
question maybe i didn't make myself
clear what i wanted to say is this is
the picture of interest in the new
government if you ask my personal
opinion the level of escalation makes
not stream 2 dead it's not happening
the european pressure the pressure from
neighboring countries the pressure from
the united states makes it very very
unlikely that germany can go on with
conditions that have drastically changed
well let's put that to both of our
guests let's begin with uh colleen
yamaya uh nordstrom 2 is dead it's quite
a strong statement i don't think it's
dead yet i don't think it's dead yet
because in the end we're dealing with
democracies and if gas prices are going
too high and people it's heat versus
food and people will
will will will go in and it's billions
and billions of dollars and it's not gas
from billions it's also iwe billions
that that went in there and just quickly
coming back to lng liquefied natural gas
yes there is us not lng that can come
into europe but we don't have that many
re-gasification terminals yet that can
take out all
the um all the all the pipeline gas
coming from the east that's that's the
first thing and let us not forget in
terms of qatar most of the gathering gas
goes towards east and china has become
very big china this year is becoming the
largest importer of lng um after japan
and korea so we have real real
competition here for the for the lng
molecules
uh pavel the same question to you the
nordstrom 2 pipeline from russia into
germany our guest in berlin says it's
effectively dead what do you think
moscow of course that would be very bad
news for a lot of people and maybe it's
not that dead actually we mean
technically it's built it's there
um if the present acute crisis over
ukraine and between russia and the west
russia nato gets some kind of
more or less permanent resolution
maybe north stream could be part of that
resolution say a kind of bonus for
russia taking
acting uh more
uh
in a more kind of consensual matters on
other places it could be part of a
quid pro quo
between russia and the west or at least
maybe germany would want to make it part
of a quid pro quo
uh so that's not most likely yet dead
but there's some serious problems that's
a fact
uh alright brooklyn you've heard what
our two guests have had to say anything
there that might have changed your mind
well
if this is a bargain chip one can
discuss it because it is very difficult
to see what other outcome could be
presented as a positive result that
moscow can present as a victory in this
confrontational situation
if this discussion would have been a
year ago i would have totally agreed
that we talk about energy and we are
dependent on imports given that germany
is fading out from nuclear and coal at
the same time
we cannot increase renewables as quickly
as necessary to
feed the energy hunger in an industrial
country like germany but now that we
face a hundred thousand russian troops
encircling ukraine
germany is not willing to
deliver arms to ukraine and everyone
else is looking at the largest country
in europe that is doesn't live up to the
expectations of nato and what ukraine
expects from germany and if we then
continue as business as usual with
opening not screen 2 then we become
completely unreliable but if this is the
bargain ship and actually what the
kremlin is mostly interested in that
they don't want to dump the billions
that have been invested in north stream
2 it might be a happy ending for
everyone involved well let's talk about
the other bargaining chip which is qatar
kolinya maya as i understand it qatar
has a number of deals with eastern
countries particularly china as you
mentioned a lot of those deals are on
25-year terms
so
how do how does that change when it
comes to spare capacity does qatar have
the ability to actually give some gas to
europe or is it all tied up in long-term
deals is there is there capacity for
qatar to get involved at the bequest of
the americans
there is capacity for qatar to get in to
get involved at the bequest of of um
of of of of america but there are
limitations to that and then let's not
forget there's australia there are other
producers of lng who can who can chip in
as well but again it becomes a matter of
price and yes we have the geopolitical
dimension but we also
have democracies we have governments who
need to get re-elected and if if costs
for heating people's houses in winter
spiral out of control it that becomes
quite tough so i'm optimistic that that
one can find some sort of accommodation
and that russia is very clear that this
is part of of their of their bargaining
strategy to find some accommodation on
north stream too and let us not forget
you know we all feel sorry for the
ukraine but you know there are it's it's
not been that clear cut clear sailing
between the ukraine and russia and
between the ukraine and europe um uh
it's it's it's it gas and paying um
energy bills and so on has been and has
been has been an issue
so
so it's it's it's it's just very very
complex indeed uh paul fulghenhauer like
where does russia back down here
is it when they get reassurances that
ukraine won't join nato which is a key
demand is it when they withdraw their
troops according to the behest of the
americans or is it simply when there's a
gas and oil diplomacy political solution
presented to them what's what's the way
out for russia here
well it's a very complex situation and
their complex actually opinions in
moscow it can't it's not that we're all
kind of marching here in
one
file
there are different opinions inside the
kremlin
and the kremlin administration of how to
deal with the situation
president putin of course is the
ultimate decision maker but he's more of
a moderator between different
serious groups of opinions
i hope that there will be of course
there will be lots of military maneuvers
they're happening right now heightened
state of military readiness and all that
stuff
which could result in a military
escalation
or it won't and the maneuvers will end
the situation will kind of calm down at
least in march april there would be time
to begin to do something on the
front of negotiations
uh so this is very complex it's not that
there's one kind of issue that changes
all the rest
uh it's a very complex uh uh situation
we are running out of time and i do want
to come to sorry we are running out of
time i do when i come to our guest in uh
berlin i mean clearly germany is a big
part of all of this where are they
hoping this situation lands
are they hoping for that it will be over
quickly or can they are they in this for
the long haul
well it's not so much a question of
timing the demand from russia
to
guarantee that nato and the european
union won't expand any further
questions the core principle of what
western organizations stand for
this is the self-determination of
nations that can decide whether they
join an organization or not so we cannot
decide over other countries whether they
send an application to join an
organization or not politically or
practically
ukraine is far from joining ever the
european union or nato this goes without
saying and everybody knows it there so i
do not really see what russia gets out
of this and if it starts with a major
statement that it is afraid of nato is
attacking
the
russian soil and in the end everything
all it gets out is the opening of
nordstream 2. it sounds a bit absurd to
me
i want to thank all our guests uh pavel
felgenhauer collina mayer and ulrich
bruckner and thank you two for watching
you can see the programme again anytime
by visiting our website aljazeera.com
and further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story and you
can also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me imran khan and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]